welcome to this episode of spectrum
thank you so much to curiosity stream
for sponsoring this episode
curiosity stream is an amazing
subscription streaming platform that has
tons of great films from documentary
nonfiction filmmakers from around the
world and you have to check it out so
make sure to click the link below and
stick around until the end to find out
how you can get 30 days spree but for
now the episode I grew up in a very
rural town in Illinois from a young age
I was just very opposed to being Asian
I'd lie I'd say oh yeah my my parents
got divorced
one of them's half I'm half I don't
really look half but whatever
[Music]
I was in the foster system so I kind of
knew I was gonna be adopted and I wasn't
adopted till I was 17 so it's a little
older than younger I mean I was adopted
when I was like seven months so my
parents told me before I even could
understand and I feel that's what all
parents should do because if you get
older and you don't know and then you
figure out that can really take a mental
toll on you I found out I was adopted at
an early age because my parents are
white how could I not know how could I
not know I was adopted you know growing
up on Long Island I dealt with a lot of
racism like even in like first grade
like people calling me like [ __ ] and
[ __ ] so I realized that obviously I was
different I would go home and I would
ask my parents like what does this mean
like what is a [ __ ] and they would have
to talk to me about it I'm also a trans
racial adoptees so it was very obvious
on top of that I also grew up in Olympia
Washington which is very white it wasn't
strange to talk about adoption they were
always very open about that and I'm very
grateful for that because again I do
know people who were not told they were
adopted and you know it just tears the
world apart
[Music]
it's just more personal issues like
family dynamics that we haven't really
gotten along it's never been like I
don't like you because you're adopted
none of that has ever been brought up
it's just
side issues and as I get older I really
distance myself from them because as I'm
becoming my own person by like views of
the world and what I believe in are
drastically different than theirs so I
think that's where our relationship has
kind of proven to be a lot more distant
my adoptive dad passed away about seven
years ago I had a really great
relationship you know he was the person
who raised me taught me you know how to
be a good person me and my older brother
I think we kind of bounced around it but
I think the reason why we're not as
close as brothers should be is because
were too adopted people I mean every
family's gonna have problems but for
them literally taking me in when I'm not
theirs and they really have no
responsibility to me and they've given
me a life they've helped me go through
college
I've always felt kind of bad to either
speak my mind compared to my sister
who's like their biological kid and even
though I know if I spoke my mind they
wouldn't say anything about me being
adopted but because they've like done so
much for me I subconsciously just felt
bad bringing stuff up and talking about
it because I was just so grateful yeah I
agree I have a very good relationship
with my parents could it be better
absolutely despite our differences and
despite some things that happened they
would die for me and that they've
sacrificed so much for me that free as
blood is thicker than water I'm like
what no like just look at people who
were adopted like they're my family I
don't even use the word adopted parents
like that's insulting to me like they're
just my parents
I guess for like a long time I had no
idea who they were you know the only
thing I really got was like papers and
like so you know stuff my mom said and
so what I found out was my mother
developed a opioid addiction even one
that was in the womb she was drinking
you know Hennessy the reason why I'm not
I'm at somewhat disagree and not
strongly disagree is because there's
still a sense of wanting because I have
no reference to say you know you're my
mother
for me I don't feel like I'm missing
anything like I feel like if you share
DNA that doesn't mean that they love you
I'm not like mad at my birth parents for
like giving me up because I feel like
they did it for like giving me a better
life and for that like I'm grateful and
my adoption was closed so I've never
like seen or like been able to meet or
talk and like I feel like that's that's
fine I just want to emphasize for my
adoption
I was actually taken away by the
government yeah so she didn't volunteer
yeah put me in the foster unit just
wanted to emphasize I was in the foster
system too and my situation is a little
different and not like a lot of foster
kids because I was been in the system
when I was 13 and I grew up with my mom
my whole life and at that point I knew
she was not fit to be a mother she was
abusive she was toxic would I go back
and see my mom no I'm not ready at least
right now because I've had to deal with
a lot of therapy dealing with PTSD from
her my bio dad also had a drug addiction
he got deported and he didn't reach out
to me tell us 13 years old and sorry I
forgot about you so I kind of just gave
up on that especially when I had this
amazing family adopt me and showed me
that they didn't care that I was the
only Mexican and a big family full of
Jews they didn't care that I look
different that I had to go to therapy
and that I had to deal with all these
things because no matter what I still
tributed to the family and they still
treated me the exact same way that they
treated their daughter so yeah it really
wasn't until actually just a few years
ago that I decided I'm actually ready to
reach out to my birth family and I had a
closed adoption so it was very very hard
to track down all this information and
you know agencies are closed after 27
years and all this stuff but I did
eventually find her on Facebook and we
have reached out we talked on the phone
now so we have like kind of a basic
communication I kind of realized that I
kind of felt fulfilled I didn't really
feel like I needed to do a whole lot
more I think eventually down the line
once I get the rest of my life together
I will like to go down there you know
meet them and meet all my siblings and
all that stuff but right now I kind of
feel okay this is a really unusual case
my birth father actually reached out to
me through the agency maybe a few didn't
maybe I wouldn't be on this line but
once he reached out to me it did make me
curious about Korea and then once I
learned the Korean language I was like
all right like I really want to get to
know these people
[Music]
growing up I would have been strongly
agree I was literally the only black
person in my town so I had no reference
of what black people were doing or what
black culture was and I did go through a
lot of the oh you talk like a white girl
you're an Oreo or you don't know every
Tupac song so you're not black enough
like all those kind of stereotypes of
what black people are supposed to be but
for me that just kind of pushed me to
learn more about black culture and read
up on our history and all that because
I'm white
I didn't face what you guys face but I
was also adopted from Russia because I
was told from a young age that I was
adopted I got to celebrate my Russian
culture and heritage I started I
strongly agree and then you mentioned
struggle is in the present and that's
what's happening now I grew up in a very
rural town in Illinois from a young age
I was just very opposed to being Asian I
was opposed to being Chinese I didn't
really suffer from racism really which I
feel very like blessed and lucky for but
I still like struggled with myself I was
like I don't like being Chinese I'd like
I'd say oh yeah my my parents got
divorced
one of them's half I'm half I don't
really look half but whatever and then
it wasn't until high school like my
sophomore year I was like I need to get
really connected with my culture cuz it
feels like there's a part of me still
missing and there will always be a part
of me missing until I actually
discovered that
it's again it's just personal issues
with me not having that blood connection
to anyone but if the adoption scenario
ever came up I would definitely not be
opposed to it it's just right now
I would want my own kids if I had them a
part of me wants to do that as well I
want to have my own child with another
part of me I want to be able to get kids
that are grown and that they're like 10
years old and their whole life has been
horrible and I'm the one that's gonna
give them a second chance but that's
only because of what I went through you
can do both absolutely but also for me I
don't want to adopt out of obligation to
feeling like I need to adopt because I'm
gonna adopt you that doesn't create a
healthy environment either like I feel
like I had to adopt I've always kind of
teetered on this line and until I
personally figure out what works best
for me I'm just nothing nothing's coming
over here for
[Music]
I think mindful is like a good word to
use just because your parents are
different race doesn't mean that they
like love you any less or anything like
that like they should be mindful and
take into consideration that you will
have like a more difficult time trying
to like navigate and stuff like that but
that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
adopt in different races when you're
adopting a child and you're taking them
into your home no matter what race they
are if you still I feel like as an
adoptive parent have responsibility to
kind of connect them to their culture
just acknowledge it you know I don't
think that you need to like go to Dia de
los Muertos because you're Mexican like
no if you want you can just no it's a
it's something that your culture does I
feel that I kind of went through an
identity crisis especially over the last
few years I'm trying to connect with my
culture I was completely unaware I was
very ignorant to it and I regret that
because I could feel a lot more
confident in myself but because I kind
of had to do it on my own because my
parents didn't do that it's been a lot
harder to identify with white Asian like
where am I in the spectrum of this I
wish they would have just like helped me
embrace the culture a little more rather
than look at me as a little child going
hate being Asian and they just laughing
oh ha ha ha because again they don't
they've never experienced that in their
life so they don't understand I feel
like mindful is a very kind of caudally
term for it for me I was called the
n-word when I was literally a child I
had people come up and sue me and pet me
like I was in a petting zoo I've gotten
spit on I've gotten all kinds of things
and I couldn't go to my family because
they don't know anything they were right
they were privileged enough to never
ever have to think about these things
but there's a whole nother set of things
that come along with raising children of
color you have to be willing to put your
life on the line for your child color
because not oh but they didn't mean it
like that oh they're just they're just
from the older generation they don't
understand no like the
those are the kind of responses I still
get to this day and it has literally
ruined relationships in my family
because they are so uncomfortable just
talking about racism you're no longer a
white family you're a family of multiple
races embrace all of it and it's time to
just put the the color bottom [ __ ]
aside and really get down to the issues
because it is literally killing people
and it's to me it's just not tolerant at
all that was off that was great I'm
gonna move on to this line over here big
thank you to our adoptees for having
this conversation and teaching us all
about something a lot of people don't
know about absolutely and thank you so
much to curiosity street for sponsoring
this episode of spectrum definitely
curiosity stream is an amazing
subscription streaming service that has
tons of titles nonfiction documentary
and for three bucks a month or twenty
bucks a year you can get unlimited
unlimited unlimited access to all of
their titles and for you good humans out
there sign up below the description link
curiosity stream comm slash jubilee
promo code jubilee for 30 days free 30
days free I usually really don't like to
leave my bed so I wash it on their
website but you can watch on like Apple
TV Roku Amazon fire xbox like literally
any smart device that's taking over the
world right now what was your favorite
series okay so my favorite series was
the six queens of King Henry the eighth
I love British history did not know
you're such a history buff hope you
enjoyed the episode thanks guys
[Music]